[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous tout cas merci pour tous
ces supporteurs qui sont présents alors
on présente en tant que présidente
enfin des femmes chefs d'entreprises de
lille mais moi ce que j'aimerais si
aujourd'hui c'est ce soir je suis là
devant vous c'est vous pour vous parler
en fait un petit peu de mon parle pas
beaucoup parce que le temps fait qu'on a
une longue vie mais déjà vous raconter
un petit peu mon histoire
au départ j'ai un parcours un petit peu
atypique parce que j'ai ce que je
voulais faire après mon bac c'était
faire une école d'assurance c'est il ya
une trentaine d'années donc à l'époque à
la réunion il n'existait pas encore
d'école et de bts
donc je te parle mauvais si mauvaise que
ça à l'école j'avais eu mon bac à ces
jeunes à 16 ans donc il fallait il
fallait que je fasse des études
donc j'ai pris j'ai pris des études de
langues et je suis allé jusqu'à bac + 4
arrivées 7 à cette fin fin d'études on
va dire donc après une maîtrise
d'anglais américain moi j'étais forte en
tout cas je me disais qu'un je parle
bien anglais je parlais bien l'espagnol
aussi et je voulais partir à paris
faire défaire des études d'interprète et
puis il ya une trentaine d'années de ça
quand j'arrivais à paris le timing
n'était pas si bon que ça finalement
parce que entre l'éducation nationale et
les vacances à la réunion n'était pas
encore en phase donc je suis arrivé en
retard et j'ai voulu profiter en fait de
cette année un petit peu sabbatique
parce que je me retrouverais finalement
une année complètement usés enfin livré
à moi-même parce que je ce que je
voulais faire c'était faire une école
d'interprète et donc pas de place et
donc j'ai eu la chance j'avais un ami
qui était à paris et donc j'allais le
voir régulièrement et travailler dans
une chaîne hôtelière un gros groupe
parisien et bon an mal an j'allais le
voir régulièrement et j'ai été j'ai été
dépistés on va dire par la direction
ce que je veux donner des informations à
des clients en anglais en espagnol et
pour moi c'était naturel donc ils m'ont
demandé de venir travailler pour eux et
c'était une chance parce que ça faisait
à peine une semaine que j'étais à paris
et je vais travailler déjà vous imaginez
j'ai signé mon premier contrat à durée
indéterminée et je ne savais même pas
que c'était un contrat à durée
indéterminée quelle chance j'avais à
peine une vingtaine d'années c'est parce
que je voulais faire mais je suis resté
quand même vite en huit ans où j'ai
progressé je passais devant j'ai fait de
la réception et puis de back-office je
suis devenu chef de réception enfin j'ai
fait un petit peu le tout et puis cette
petite voix qui me disait mais celle
datant sais pas ce que tu veux faire
c'est bien un examen dans dans
l'hôtellerie c'est bien tu rencontres du
monde
par rapport à mes études que ce que
j'avais fait je parlais l'anglais
l'espagnol est là c'était chouette que
j'avais appris à comprendre le jargon
hôtelier allemand italien langue oui
c'était c'était plaisant puis cette
fille parisienne mois qu'il était je ne
suis pas réunionnaise donc je suis
désignée je suis né aux comores de
parents indiens
donc ça faisait un petit mélange comme
ça sur le sang indien et donc la vie
parisienne était très chouette et puis
au bout de au bout de ses militants je
veux plus je vous dis pas on était très
impayés on avait quand même à l'époque
je pense qu'aujourd'hui c'est même plus
pensable
on avait 16 mois de salaire et puis moi
cette petite voix qui me disait chez les
verts mais attends tu vas pas rester
quand même dans l'hôtellerie c'est parce
que tu as envie de faire ce que tu as
envie de faire c'est les assurances
alors comment je ne savais pas je n'ai
aucune idée de ce que je voulais je mais
je savais que ça tu as envie de faire de
l'assurance
donc voyez comme quoi il ya peut-être
que maintenant on me dirait du vin
démissionner et puis partir laventure je
le ferai pas mais il s'est fait je les
fais au bout de quelques années dont
huit ans passés dans ce gros goût et
puis au lieu au lieu de fin de négocier
mon départ est ou non sur un coup de
tête
ça c'est moi c'est tout moi ça et je
suis parti et sur les donc à l'époque
avait même pas internet
vous imaginez on était sûr militaire
donc voilà ça fait de beaux souvenirs
comme donc je suis parti sur cette
petite boîte d'aller rechercher des
courtiers en assurance
voilà ce que je voulais faire donc j'en
ai fait un premier je vous propose mes
services et made in on écoute et on n'a
pas le temps de vous former si vous
n'avez pas fait d'études ne voulais pas
refaire bts ben je suis un homme j'ai
rien fait mais j'ai vraiment envie de
travailler
j'ai enfin le deuxième est lui carrément
écoutez moi je suis à la retraite j'ai
pas le temps de former voyez avec les
commerciaux s'ils veulent bien vous
prendre sous leur aile j mais c'est pas
possible du pasj va ressortir de là
comme ça je vais pas refaire plusieurs
courtiers je reviens de voir je lui ai
dit écoutez moi je veux bien travailler
trois mois gratuitement pour vous mais
je voudrais apprendre
je pense qu'aujourd'hui aucun des jeunes
vous irez ce genre de choses trois mois
très rapidement fait c'est pratiquement
impensable mais je les fais et donc
voilà il m'a donné cette chance je suis
resté donc avec ses commerciaux j'avais
j'avais droit à des formations
j'ai repris un peu d'études ont donc ce
qui m'a permis d'avancer beaucoup plus
vite j'ai refait des études dans les
assurances avec des formations internes
des formations externes et puis surtout
c'était sur le terrain
donc voilà j'ai commencé je
j'adorais franchement c'était j'avais
trouvé ma foi je me suis dit tiens voilà
ça fait laisser passer presque huit ans
mais 8
et bien finalement je me suis rendu
compte que j'avais et c'est stella bonne
voie donc j'ai fait les j'ai fait ce
parcours d'assurance donc au bout de
trois ans vous imaginez moi qui qui
n'avait pas fait d'études ni fait un bts
d'assurance où j'avais quand même un
niveau
eh bien j'avais réussir à voir une
petite équipe de 15 personnes
c'était c'était sympa une petite équipe
de 15 personnes et j'avais négocié donc
avec les la compagnie d'avoir une
surprime parce que bon elle était
parfois de la gabin j'avais seize mois
de salaire sur sur cette chaîne
hôtelière et relais viennent qu'on pense
à un moment donné parce que quand on est
commercial et des hauts et des bas et
c'était pas évident et donc avec cette
petite équipe gt gt vraiment forte salle
tout allait bien c'était c'était
plaisant de vivre à paris bien sûr quand
tout va bien
forcément il faut bien qu'ils aient des
mauvaises nouvelles
tout ne peut pas être lisse et parfait
ça prend ce moment là que ben mon
beau-père et à des soucis taux d cancer
généralisé donc il faut et mon conjoint
d'époque ne pensait qu'à rentrer voulait
rentrer à la réunion malgré qu'on avait
une belle carrière tous les deux non il
voulait rentrer ses épaules et puis
c'est un peu normal parce que on a on
n'a qu'une seule famille surtout papa
maman donc rendre à la réunion est moins
forte de cette expérience déjà c'était
pas énorme mais c'était que trois ans
seulement dans les assurances mais je
j'avais une force en moi et je me suis
dit non non c'est pas grave ou rentrer à
la réunion je propose mes services et je
ne voulais surtout pas devenir salarié
nos bus était d'être indépendant
d'être en freelance travaillé pour
plusieurs compagnies et forte de st
quand je suis arrivé effectivement ça
n'a pas tardé totalité plus ou moins
lisse on m'a dit j'ai réussi à remonter
une petite iq est pas la réunion et puis
ça fait déjà plus de mains en vingt ans
et il ya vingt ans de ça j'ai commencé à
mettre en place on fait des stands des
stands dans l'est dans les centres
commerciaux
ce qui ne se faisait pas non plus sur la
réunion c'était tout nouveau envoyé des
stands de de pas mal de choses mais
certainement pas là c'était l'assureur
qui venait vers le public
les genres il était un peu étonné mais
ça très bien fonctionné donc très
contente de rentrer à la réunion il ya
un effet beau on est du pays
puis c'est beaucoup plus plaisant que
quand même paris on a le soleil tous les
jours c'est agréable et l'appareil
encore une fois une petite mauvaise
d'une grande mauvaise nouvelle parce
qu'après plein de choses en découle est
décollée de ça j'avais ma première et ma
grande fille dont elle est emballée
tombe malade une quinte de toux et 20
jours de combats 20 journaux comme un
diagnostic de médecin
elle est on va dire quand l état
végétatif à légumes vous dit mince à
préserver tous à votre vie va bien
professionnellement tout va bien et là
c'est pas la bonne nouvelle c'est dur
c'est très très dur d'accepter ça c'est
ma première et je me suis dit qu'est ce
que je fais est-ce que je baisse les
bras
c'était pas déjà dans mon caractère
baisser les bras par rapport à mon
parcours et puis et puis c'était c'était
mon en forme et puis de médecins ils
vous racontent des bobards je dis pas
qu'ils voient racontent des bobards mais
on comprend pas trop un peu dans leur
jargon
le milieu médical est très dur et puis
c'est vrai que quand il vous dit ça ne
marchera plus elle parlera plus elle
fera pas grand chose bon d'accord
et puis vous avez envie d'accepter ça en
fait je n'avais pas du tout envie
d'accepter cette cet handicap est ce que
je le jeu petit à petit quand elle s'est
réveillée effectivement oui bah oui
c'est instinct constat elle et elle est
présente elle marche au plus parle plus
mais je me suis dit non il faut il faut
se battre et c'est en fait si vous
voulez ce point là qui a été très très
important qu'un avis vous n'allez pas me
dire le contraire quand on a des enfants
c'était ça ce qui m'a fait si vous
voulez aller vers l'avant mais pour tous
alors effectivement j'étais au départ en
simple commercial en assurance
mais j'avais envie de démontrer un petit
pas tout le monde on pouvait qu'on
pouvait réussir qu'on pouvait que si on
voulait on se donnait les moyens
vous pouvez y aller jusqu'au bout de par
mes origines en plus voilà comme je
voudrais dire je parle plusieurs langues
je mange je parle la langue maternelle
on faisait des petits signes en me
disant tiens pourquoi pas maintenant que
tu es dans l'océan indien sur madagascar
et sur mayotte ya des besoins en
assurance et voilà que je veux par tous
les mois je mens avec ma petite manette
d'assurance et je les faire des contrats
et j'étais spécialisé dans les dents la
retraite dans les contrats de vie c'est
la partie la plus dure on les assurances
donc deux années ont passé et me voilà à
la tête en fait si vous voulez d'un
certain nombre de deux pareils comme en
métropole de commerciaux et surtout
forte d'un chiffre d'affaires qui fait
qu'on ne me nomme pourtier je ne deviens
pas mais on ne me dit on me demande ce
passage on me dit voilà il faut
maintenant que tu t'installes avec des
agences déjà une première agence au
départ et que je prenne
faites une carte est ce parce que je
voulais faire en fait je ne voulais pas
m'imposer
juste une carte d'assurance je voulais
vraiment prendre la place d'un courtier
je ne sais pas si vous connaissez la
différence entre courtiers
et puis être un agent un agent il a une
carte d'une maison mère et puis le
courtier lui il voit la recherche en
fait de plusieurs produits qui lui plaît
et il peut travailler avec plusieurs
compagnies et c'est ce que je voulais
faire je voulais vraiment être service
de mes clients et non pas plutôt vendre
pour la compagnie
je voulais vraiment satisfaire mes
clients avec les bons produits produits
d'assurance
donc voilà je me suis installé à la
réunion une agence deux agences j'en ai
eu cinq au total
donc vous voyez n'ayant pas fait
d'études d'assurance quand même je suis
arrivé il y avait aussi de l'autre côté
ce besoin de m'occuper de ma fille parce
que c'était important
comme je vous disais un diagnostic très
très méchant mais bon je suis hyper fier
parce qu'elle est là aujourd'hui elle
vit sa vie
et puis elle le diagnostic je veux pas
dire c'était faux mais voilà il ya eu la
volonté je les fait souffrir
ça a été dur mais elle est là elle est
là elle travaille elle part à l'école et
les mérites de droite avaient redoublé
jamais été dans une école spécialisée
donc c'est important c'était assez de la
parenthèse dans la vie
je vais lui dire que je te rend vraiment
fière d'elle parce que c'est elle qui
peut de la force en fait si vous voulez
d'avancé c'est aussi mon titre la chance
d'avancer c'est de rondelle que je puise
aujourd'hui
et puis sur ce parcours là si vous
voulez pendant cette période d'assurance
j'ai rencontré une femme qui est venue
me voir et qui m'a proposé en fait
d'être dans une association départ
génitaux parce que si vous voulez le
parcours de sarah ma grande fille a fait
que je voulais je voulais m'intégrer
dans l'est dans les associations dans 10
cas mais s'était jamais le s'était
jamais je dirai comment vous dire on me
disait soit n'était pas sans handicap et
pourrait dans le monde et va lire soit
l'été elle était trop valide pour être
dans le monde des handicapés récemment
j'avais un projet d'association jeunes
dit mince alors comment je vais faire
donc bon j'ai fait avec ce que j'ai pu
entendre en tant que maman
et puis j'en suis fier en tout cas mais
cette association quand on est venu me
voir c'était l'association est bien des
femmes chefs d'entreprise j'étais
vraiment au départ je suis en train tant
que membre et puis comme tout ce que je
fais je vais jusqu'au bout et je suis
allé à fond ça va faire maintenant plus
de 10 ans je suis dans cette association
et je suis la présidente de
l'association des femmes chefs
d'entreprise et cette association de
nouri finalement aussi à travers travers
des rencontres à travers ces femmes qui
sont passionnés qui ont envie de créer
qui y sont qui sont un reflet de ce que
j'étais et que je le suis toujours
c'est un c'est quelque chose de très
très enrichissant en tout cas pour moi
chaque rencontre est belle et puis
l'association me porte aussi et donc ça
vous permet peu importe le tir est ce
que vous faites
et le combat que vous menez moi j'ai
envie de vous dire que c'est important
de voir aussi un rêve ou d'avoir
l'objectif on parlait tout à l'heure et
loïs des loups a parlé d'objectif c'est
important d'en avoir un et moi je trouve
ça il faut il faut le garder il faut le
garder en vous pour pouvoir avancer
c'est vrai que le fait d'être dans cette
association ça me fait quand même une
dizaine d'années quand même que j'y suis
donc on parle de l'entrepreneuriat et
l'entrepreneuriat c'est on le disait
tout à l'heure que c'est ne pas faire un
business plan pour entreprendre c'est
aussi un moyen d'entreprendre cette mais
moi je les fais gg c'est j'ai pas eu ce
format en fait de business plan ni de
quoi que ce soit je les fais parce que
voilà ses services et où je disais un
moment donné j'ai une vie facile et pas
si facile que ça parce que bon j'ai eu
des parcours un petit peu difficile mais
ma propre vie a été facile parce que je
me suis pas mis des barrières en fait et
et c'est important
c'est important ces barrières que vous
mettez ce sont les vôtres et donc il
pour avancer alesi et vivez votre je
dirais vivez votre rêve et puis avancez
avec ça l'objectif convenu que vous avez
vous voilà voilà un petit peu parce que
c'est vrai qu'on parle toujours de
présidente de l'association des femmes
chefs d'entreprise c'est là je vous ai
parlé un petit peu de mon pas et vous
pourquoi et comment je fais pour être là
merci à vous
[Applaudissements]